in death of a generation
history professor howard jones considers
the impact that the assassinations of
u.s president kennedy and south
vietnamese president diem had on the
vietnam war
this history on book tv feature from the
national archives in washington dc
lasts an hour
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the national archives my name
is sam anthony and i'm your host for
tonight's lecture and book signing we
are honored to have with us dr howard
jones he will discuss his book death of
a generation how the assassinations of
zim and jfk prolong the vietnam war
dr
jones comes to us all the way from the
university of alabama
after teaching at the university of
nebraska for two years he went to the
university of alabama in 1974
where he is now the university research
professor of the department of history
a recipient of both the john f burnham
distinguished faculty award for teaching
and research and the frederick moody
blackmon's sarah mccorkle moody award
for bringing recognition to the
university
he teaches courses in american foreign
relations and the u.s vietnam war
dr jones has spent many an hour here at
the national archives and in the jfk
presidential library and the lbj
presidential library researching this
book and you can do that too the
national archives has billions of
records whether it be textual documents
photographs motion pictures and whether
it was cited in this book or not you can
come here to the national archives
yourself and carry out your own research
so if you'd like to learn more about the
national archives our programs our
records
ask me some questions my information is
in the program
or go to our website at archives.gov
well let's not
stop anymore how about i introduce to
you dr howard jones he comes all the way
from tuscaloosa alabama and by the way
he received his ph.d from the university
of indiana it gives me great pleasure to
introduce to you howard jones
[Applause]
i thank you very much for coming out
this evening i thank sam for having me
here at the national archives it's
always a wonderful occasion to come to
this place
if president john f kennedy had lived he
would not have sent combat troops to
vietnam
and america's longest war would never
have occurred
so say kennedy apologists
his assassination on november 22 1963
they insist
had killed more than the president it
was responsible for the death of a
generation of more than 58 000 americans
along with untold numbers of vietnamese
on both sides of the 17th parallel
when i began this study i was dubious
about these assertions but as my
research progressed many of my doubts
disappeared
president kennedy had long regarded the
war as south vietnam's alone to win or
lose
and made every effort short of direct
u.s combat involvement to turn the
verdict in saigon's favor
he staunchly resisted the relentless
pressure for combat troops that came
from both military and civilian advisers
but critically important he never called
for a total withdrawal
kennedy hoped that american assistance
would improve south vietnam's fighting
performance to the extent that it could
bring the insurgency under control
by the spring of 1962
he sought to roll back the u.s military
involvement to the less provocative
advisory level he had inherited when
taking office more than a year earlier
by the time of the president's
assassination he had come close to
finalizing a process for withdrawing
most of america's soldiers in accordance
with the comprehensive plan for south
vietnam
the recently released kennedy white
house tapes show that both he and
secretary of defense robert mcnamara had
become convinced by the fall of 1963
that the united states should start the
phased withdrawal
once the army of the republic of vietnam
arvind had pushed back the viet cong
and after kennedy had won re-election in
1964
he would continue the withdrawal program
aimed at having the great bulk of u.s
soldiers home in sixty five
those remaining behind would number
fifteen hundred
all advisors and well within the
strictures of the geneva accords of
nineteen fifty four
this withdrawal effort stalled in the
wake of the buddhist uprising of may
1963
and ultimately came to a halt by the end
of the year
what had happened in the meantime
in a tragically misguided move president
kennedy followed secretary of state dean
rust's advice
and promoted the general's coup in late
1963
thinking that a change of government
would improve the war effort and thereby
facilitate the u.s withdrawal
consequently when the arvind generals
staged their coup in early november
they did so with full knowledge of
american approval
south vietnamese premier no din ziem's
crude handling of the buddhist crisis
had combined with the arvind's bumbling
war effort
the kennedy administration's open
criticisms of the regime and the
persistent rumors of saigon's secret
negotiations with hanoi to drive the
generals into a coup that culminated in
the deaths of both ziem and his brother
no denu
the two assassinations opened a visceral
division among the coup makers and led
to renewed domestic turmoil
then in the short span of three weeks
president kennedy himself lay dead
and with him the comprehensive plan for
south vietnam
for good reason historians are reluctant
to speculate on what might have happened
in vietnam had president kennedy lived
it is not speculation however to examine
his policies toward vietnam
in an effort to discern whether or not a
pattern of withdrawal was in the making
kennedy salt sought to halt the move
toward americanizing the war in a
process that president richard nixon
would call vietnamization
but so deep was the kennedy
administration's involvement in these
events that it could not have escaped
blame for the coup regardless of what it
did or did not do
kennedy had encouraged a coup that got
out of hand and led to zim's death
rather than his exile
and yet had kennedy live to win
reelection there is no reason to believe
that he would have changed his views
about wanting to get out of a war that
had become a lost cause
the story of this policy failure begins
in the spring of 1962
when the apparent progress in the war
encouraged the first talk of military
reductions
at a high level conference in honolulu
on july 23rd
general paul harkins the ever optimistic
commander of the military assistance
command vietnam makvy
presented a glowing report on the war
which heightened the move toward partial
withdrawal
president kennedy had instructed
mcnamara to devise a formula for
implementing the process
the ensuing comprehensive plan for south
vietnam aimed at enabling the south
vietnamese government to police its own
affairs quote without the need for
continued us special military assistance
by the end of 1965.
not everyone shared this confidence in
late 1962 president kennedy's longtime
friend senator mike mansfield submitted
a dismal report on vietnam and called
for its neutralization
after mansfield left a tense two-hour
meeting with the president at his palm
beach retreat in florida
kennedy moaned to aid kenneth o'donnell
i got angry with mike for disagreeing
with our policy so completely
and i got angry with myself because i
found myself agreeing with him
the perceived progress in the war took
another jolt when two of the president's
closest advisors roger hillsman and
michael forestall
returned from saigon to confirm many of
mansfield's pessimistic observations
and yet quixotically predicted victory
albeit over a longer period than at
first thought
the cia meanwhile warned against a
deadly war of attrition
asserting that the zm regime was the
root of the trouble
and ominously reporting that 400
regulars from the people's army of
vietnam
in the north had just entered south
vietnam armed with chinese weapons
finally on january 2nd and 3rd 1963
a huge arvind and civil guard contingent
suffered what hillsman termed a quote
stunning defeat in quote at app back
in the mekong delta just 35 miles
southwest of saigon
for the first time viet cong gorillas
had stood their ground
raising doubts about the prospects of
victory
more or less beginning then
forestall later recalled
kennedy began to get worried about
vietnam
president kennedy rejected an immediate
withdrawal as an admission to defeat
in the oval office he admitted to
mansfield that his call for a military
withdrawal was correct
but i can't do it until 1965
after i'm reelected
otherwise there would be a wild
conservative outcry in the election
campaign that would have severe
political repercussions
after mansfield left the room kennedy
confided confided his intentions to
o'donnell who had also been present
in 1965 i will become one of the most
unpopular presidents in history
i'll be damned everywhere as a communist
appeaser but i don't care
if i tried to pull out completely now
from vietnam we would have another joe
mccarthy red scare in our hands but i
can do it after i'm reelected
so we had better make damn sure i am
re-elected
in the spring of 1963 the withdrawal
plan appeared to be nearing completion
on march 7 the joint chiefs signified
approval
and on may 6th the president's advisors
met in honolulu to draft the details
but the entire program came to a
standstill just two days later
when during the early evening hours of
may the 8th violence erupted in the
imperial capital of way during the
nationwide celebrations of buddha's
birthday
disturbances rapidly spread to saigon
and other cities as buddhist monks
protested against alleged religious
discrimination and terrorism by sam's
catholic dominated government
and claimed to have a mandate from
heaven to launch a revolution aimed at
securing religious freedom
the most spectacular event came on june
the 11th
when a buddhist monk emulated himself on
a crowded street in downtown saigon
blindsiding the kennedy administration
a buddhist barbecue
madame knew acidly remarked
clapping her hands in glee and calling
the protest communist inspired
how could this have happened the
president stormed a forest all who are
these people
the buddhist crisis pushed the kennedy
administration closer to ending its
support of zim
and paradoxically into a more tangled
involvement in vietnam
russ pointedly told charges william
truhart in saigon quote
if zim does not take prompt and
effective steps to re-establish buddhist
confidence in him we will have to
re-examine our entire relationship with
his regime
the white house knew that a hard-line
position towards the m could encourage a
coup
and yet it took the first step in that
direction by appointing republican henry
cabot lodge junior
as new ambassador to south vietnam
lodge would also serve as the
president's quote personal
representative end quote
meaning that he would report directly to
kennedy
cia director john mcconne believed that
lodge had private instructions from the
president to warn zim
that if he failed to get rid of his
brother and change his government the
new ambassador was to quote use his
influence to bring about a change in the
top leadership end quote
but before lodge's arrival the domestic
crisis intensified when shortly after
midnight on august 21
heavily armed government forces launched
a brutal crackdown on buddhist pagodas
throughout south vietnam
truckloads of steel helmeted combat
police and army camouflage uniforms
joined red beret special forces in
arresting more than fourteen hundred
bonds and charging them with possessing
weapons
the pagoda raids quote mark the end of
the dm regime
lodge later remarked
firing at people in worship made it just
a matter of time before they would be
through
trueheart asserted that the white house
never made a serious effort to get
behind zim again
lodge tried to prevent any precipitous
u.s action but is cautionary august 24
telegram arrived in washington on a
saturday afternoon
when as fate would have it those few
advisers on duty were the most outspoken
opponents of the dm regime
forestall hillsman and veteran hard-line
diplomat avril harriman anxiously read
lodge's account of the raids
noting that it confirmed their
suspicions that knew had been
responsible
indeed new had secured army uniforms for
the government's forces
shifting the blame to the generals and
thereby infuriating the group that had
the greatest potential for staging a
successful coup
the ensuing telegram 243
sent to lodge and drafted primarily by
harriman hillsman and forestall
declared that if zim refused to remove
new
we must face the possibility that zim
himself cannot be preserved
president kennedy realized that his
approval of telegram 243
would promote a coup and later called it
quote a major mistake in quote his
brother attorney general robert kennedy
put it bluntly
the result is we started down a road
that we never really recovered from
but the impetus for a coup surprisingly
fizzled
the generals refused to proceed without
a specific assurance of u.s support and
that assurance never came
and yet the white house had not closed
the door on fostering a coup
at a morning meeting of the national
security council on september 6
russ convincingly argued
that to facilitate a u.s withdrawal from
vietnam the administration quote might
want to consider promoting a coup
beforehand
that objective in mind
lodge proposed that former cia operative
and now air force general edward
lansdale mastermind a coup
a risky venture it was
but the full measure of the
administration's desperation became
clear when president kennedy invited
lansdale to the white house to discuss
the proposal
soon after lansdale accepted the
invitation mcnamara showed up in his
limousine at the pentagon and offered
him a ride to the meeting the defense
secretary escorted lansdale into the
room and took a chair
the meeting would be about cuba lansdale
must have guessed his most recent
assignment had been to head the secret
program code-named operation mongoose
that aimed to topple fidel castro
the president however raised an entirely
different matter
would you return to vietnam an attempt
to persuade zim to remove his brother
and wife from the country
yes lansdale replied at long last the
administration had come to realize what
he had known for a long time the news
were the problem not his old friend zim
the president had more in mind however
but if that didn't work out
or i changed my mind and decided we had
to get rid of ziem
would you be able to go along with that
a deafening silence although mcnamara
sat in the room lansdale could not have
been aware of anyone but the president
was he thinking exile lansdale must have
asked himself
if so lansdale realized that bloodless
coups were rare
he also knew that ziem would choose
death over leaving his country
was the president proposing zim's
assassination
president kennedy's words were purposely
vague in meaning and lansdale's long
experience with the cia had taught him
never to seek clarification and
instructions
no mr president shaking his head slowly
i couldn't do that
zim is my friend
the meeting was over
the president tried to smooth over what
had transpired
but his small talk did nothing to erase
the paul of the underworld that had just
visited the room
lansdale would not be going to
vietnam in the limousine afterward
mcnamara angrily lashed out at lansdale
as they returned to the pentagon you
don't talk to the president of the
united states that way when he asks you
to do something you don't tell him you
won't do it
is the story credible
according to both investigative reporter
seymour hirsch
and a.j landgath a new york times
correspondent in south vietnam during
the 1960s
lansdale related these events to daniel
ellsberg the defense department official
responsible for the pentagon papers
both landeth and ellsberg believe
lansdale's story
but in an interview of mcnamara
conducted by langeth years afterward the
former defense secretary alleged that he
did not recall that meeting
mcnamara's claim to a memory lapse was
not surprising
for he could not remember other meetings
he had attended while in office some of
which dealt with the subject of
assassinations
during the mid-1970s the church
committee of the u.s senate
investigated assassinations of the
previous decade and asked him about
operation mongoose
the then president of the world bank had
come under media fire for his alleged
participation in a special committee
discussion on august 10 1962 regarding
the assassination of castro
mcnamara could not recall being there
and vehemently denied any knowledge of
assassination plans either before or
during his time in office
i believe then he told the committee
that the u.s government should not
undertake or encourage assassination
openly or secretly as an instrument of
national policy against people with whom
we're not at war
assassination is totally inconsistent
with my moral standards now and then
the evidence amassed by the church
committee raised serious questions about
mcnamara's testimony
particularly damaging was a memo of
august 14 1962
in which william harvey chief of the cia
task force on cuba
claimed that at a meeting in rus office
on august 10
mcnamara raised the question of
assassination quote particularly of
fidel castro in quote
the senior administration members
present were shocked
that the defense secretary had used the
word liquidation in a formal meeting
mccone according to an observer got red
in the face
and made known his intention to stop any
such proposals suggestion or any
discussion thereof at that meeting
within that forum immediately
he and edward r murrell from the u.s
information agency hotly declared the
subject out of order and the secretary
of the meeting did not record the
discussion in the minutes
mccone felt so strongly that he
telephoned mcnamara later that same day
stressing that he not raised the matter
again
but the issue would not go away
on april 23 1963 mcnamara attended a top
level meeting where he according to the
note taker quote made clear his belief
that the elimination of the castro
regime was a requirement in quote and in
mid 1975 richard goodwin latin american
specialist in the state department
during the 1960s told members of the
select committee that at a cuban task
force meeting after the bay of pigs
episode mcnamara suggested quote getting
rid of castro
when someone from the cia asked if he
meant by executive action mcnamara
affirmed that he did
this brief digression from vietnam
strongly suggests a pattern in
mcnamara's behavior
it's difficult to believe that he forgot
all those discussions about eliminating
castro
how could the defense secretary fail to
recall his own recommendations for
assassination
better yet is it likely that he would
forget mccone's admonition not once but
twice
about raising the subject in formal
discussions
the records show that mcnamara attended
many of these meetings relating to
operation mongoose
lansdale claimed that the secretary was
present at the private 1963 conference
with the president
lansdale was devious and manipulative by
trade but it is incomprehensible that he
would fabricate a clandestine meeting
that tied the secretary of defense and
the president of the united states to an
assassination proposal
evidence of the white house meeting with
fitz
with other features of this sensitive
period
lodge had a direct connection with the
white house as the president's personal
representative which implied a special
status that could cover the exchange of
delicate information
the president had approved telegram 243
which had told lodge that if zim refused
to remove his brother the white house
would support the elimination of the
premier
lodge was not naive he was certainly
aware of lansdale's propensity to stray
beyond his orders
it is really a pity lodge lamented to
rusk had my request been granted i
believe the coup might have been pulled
off
unknown to everyone except mcnamara and
lansdale however the president had been
willing to give lodge's proposal a
chance
if the president had doubts about the
u.s military effort he became even more
uncertain after hearing the mixed report
of another first-hand inspection of
vietnam
at a national security council meeting
on september 10
the two mission leaders presented
diametrically opposed assessments of the
war
presidents kennedy's frustration became
evident in his cryptic remark the two of
you did visit the same country didn't
you
the white house opted for a series of
escalating pressures ostensibly designed
to force governmental reform
but that it knew had the capacity to
encourage a coup
to persuade ziem to make changes
president kennedy dispatched another
special mission to saigon in
mid-september
headed by mcnamara and the president's
special advisor general maxwell taylor
it concluded that the administration
should accelerate the phased withdrawal
program
on october 2nd president kennedy took
the initial step by deciding to withdraw
the first contingent of 1 000 u.s
military forces from vietnam by the end
of the year
his decision was unconditional for he
approved a calendar of events that did
not necessitate a victory
indeed as confidante john kenneth
galbraith insisted years afterward
implicit in all his conversations with
the president during this pivotal period
was quote the realization that victory
was not possible in quote
the white house approved a program of
selective short-term pressures that were
primarily economic and in proportion to
the regime's improved performance
i think mcnamara told the president we
must have a means of disengaging from
this area and we must show our country
that means
in reality however this step was the one
most coveted by the generals as a signal
of u s interest in a coup
the authors of the report realized this
and asserted that the administration
must establish contacts with quote an
alternative leadership if and when it
appears
two days later taylor now joint chief's
chair informed his colleagues that the
military withdrawal was one of president
kennedy's quote approved actions for
south vietnam
robert kennedy recommended downplaying
the move by making no formal
announcement and carrying out the
process in a routine way
let's just go ahead and do it the
president declared
in this highly charged atmosphere the
chances of a coup regained momentum on
october 2nd at saigon's airport cia
operative lucian conin
codenamed black luigi lulu
wore a military uniform signifying the
rank of lieutenant colonel
conin encountered south vietnamese
general trung van dome
who had been trying to contact his old
friend for some time could they meet
that night
yes responded conan not hesitating to
make the 200 mile trip to a spot
northeast of saigon
in an hour-long session dome emphasized
that the generals now have a plan
in an hour-long session we now have a
plan their leader general dwang van min
big men
wanted to meet with conan at joint
general headquarters in saigon big men
informed coneen that a coup was about to
take place and that he needed us
assurance of military and economic
assistance afterward
in a response that william colby former
cia station chief and later cia director
termed a green light to the generals
conan followed lodge's directive in
promising that the united states would
not obstruct a coup
and would provide help following its
success
the generals intended to leave zim in
office as figurehead but to assassinate
his brother new and to others
if a difference existed between
promoting a coup and doing nothing to
stop one that distinction was narrow
particularly since the major player on
the scene was the united states
the kennedy administration had furnished
the trigger to the coup by cutting
assistance to the regime and promising
economic and military help to the
generals once they took over the
government
furthermore in remaining silent about
men's assassination plan it had lost any
potential control over events
in the heat of the moment could the
assassins guarantee them safety
the coup erupted in saigon during the
afternoon of november 1.
men had gathered all the rebel generals
in a show of strength before telephoning
zhao long palace at 4 45 pm and
demanding a surrender
new bitterly asserted that zam was not
there and refused to surrender
diem had five minutes to resign men
hotly retorted otherwise the generals
would launch a massive artillery assault
on the palace
not waiting for a reply he slammed down
the phone
less than a half hour he called again
asking for zim
but the premier refused to talk with him
and hung up the phone
men was furious over this loss of face
at 7 15 p.m he tried one last time
warning knew that if ziem did not
surrender the rebel forces would quote
blast him off the face of the earth end
quote them would not come to the phone
men's colleagues expressed concern that
further delay would work to zim's
advantage had he not risen from the
ashes in 1960
conin invited to rebel headquarters to
become part of the events warn men if
you hesitate you will be lost
men had no choice but to lay siege on
the palace
shortly after three am the assault began
ending a little more than three hours
later with zim's unconditional surrender
men arrived on the smoky scene at 8 00
a.m on november 2nd
in full military dress uniform and ready
to supervise the transportation of ziem
and his brother to command headquarters
for a pre-arranged surrender ceremony
according to conan most of the officers
including men had changed their minds
about retaining zim in office and now
wanted him to have an honorable
retirement followed by exile
their overriding concern was to
orchestrate an orderly transition in
government that would win international
acceptance of the coup
men intended to personally escort zim
and new back to headquarters where with
full press coverage they would all sit
at a green felt covered table while zim
formally relinquished power to the vice
president
after the proceeding ziem would ask for
asylum in a fully broadcasted event
the generals would grant the request
stipulating that he and knew remain in
custody until the aircraft whisked them
out of the country
none of this happened
the brothers were not in the palace
zim and new had fled through a
subterranean tunnel and jumped into a
waiting car that took them away
humiliated before his peers men was
livid that zim and new had stolen away
in the night
but the worst news was yet to come
zim and new were dead
a little after midnight on november 2nd
the cia notified the white house that
vietnam radio had announced their deaths
by poison
taken while prisoners and an armored
personnel carrier transporting them from
the city to the rebel command post
harkins however reported the claim of
death by self-destruction
either by gunshot or by a grenade
wrestled from the belt of an arvin
officer
death by accidental suicide asserted the
generals in the face of the catholic
brothers beliefs
men explained in trying to clear up the
discrepancy that due to an inadvertence
there was a gun inside the vehicle it
was with this gun that they committed
suicide
the truth behind the two brothers deaths
began to seep out after men had ordered
a search of all areas frequented by the
no family he learned of their escape to
the chinese sector of cologne where they
sought refuge in a catholic church a few
minutes later just before 10 am two
jeeps and an armored personnel carrier
screeched into the narrow alcove housing
the church building
in command was general maihu suong a
long time enemy of zims swung dispatched
his men into the building to bring out
the brothers once outside ziem requested
a brief stop at the palace to gather
personal items before his flight out of
vietnam swan turned him down coldly
stating that his orders were to take
them to headquarters one brash young
officer asked to shoot new no reply
swung
new express disgust at zim's having to
ride in an armored car you used such a
vehicle to drive the president
swung angrily ordered the brothers hands
tied behind their backs and shoved them
into the carrier as he jumped into a
jeep to head the convoy zim and new
found themselves sitting in the carrier
with two men
captain dwang hu na who was at the
turret of the armored vehicle and
captain nguyen van neum men's personal
aid and bodyguard newm was an assassin
by trade who already had put 40 marks on
his revolver his animosity towards him
ran second only to his visceral hatred
for new
en route to the general's headquarters
noom killed zim and new
na explained what had happened
as we rode back to the joint quarters
zim sat silently but knew and the
captain began to insult each other i
don't know who started it the name
calling grew passionate the captain had
hated knew before now he was charged
with emotion when the convoy stopped for
a train newm lunged at new with a
bayonet and stabbed him again and again
maybe 15 or 20 times still in a rage he
turned to zim took out his revolver and
shot him in the head then he looked back
at new who was lying on the floor
twitching he put a bullet into his head
too neither sam nor new ever defended
themselves their hands were tied
the cia and saigon had meanwhile secured
a set of snapshots that left no doubt of
a double assassination taken around 10
a.m on november 2nd they showed the two
dead brothers covered with blood on the
floor of an armored vehicle dressed in a
roman catholic's priests robes hands
tied behind their backs faces bloodied
and bruised their bodies beaten and
stabbed repeatedly the pictures appeared
all over the world
suicide with no hands
read the caption in the time magazine
the administration's dire suspicions
materialized into fact when it became
certain that men had ordered noom to
kill zim and new
coneen turned the term the general a
very proud man who had lost face
their decision to flee was one of the
things that ticked off men and he gave
the order
testimony later from various others
indicated that men alone had carried out
the order
pretty stupid
uttered president kennedy barely above a
whisper before stunned cabinet members
diem's assassination implicated all the
generals and drove their initial harmony
into ranked discord dome abhorred the
killings caustically insisting that he
and his cohort had furnished the armored
car in an effort to protect zim and new
not kill them and yet dome and the
others failed to realize that all
conspirators bore responsibility for the
deaths by participating in the coup
in a similar manner president kennedy
and his advisors likewise bore
culpability
the white house had promoted the coup at
its most critical moment
when its leaders needed only a nod from
washington as dome and all the other
generals involved in the coup shared
guilt for the assassinations of ziem and
new so did the u.s government take its
place as an accomplice admittedly
unexpected developments in the coup led
to the decision to kill zim
but as colby later asserted it's
something that you have to anticipate
may take place in the event of an
overthrow of a government
in accordance with russ's earlier
argument the administration used the
coup's success to justify withdrawal
before a press conference on november 14
president kennedy asserted that at the
scheduled honolulu conference in six
days his advisors would develop detailed
plans for the initial troop withdrawal
presidential adviser mcgeorge bundy
afterward drafted a national security
action memo based on the honolulu
proceedings that he expected president
kennedy to sign as a precursor to
withdrawal in the late afternoon of
thursday november 21
forestall spoke with the president in
the oval office just hours before his
departure for texas
looking to the near future the president
asserted i want you to come and see me
because we have to start to plan for
what we're going to do now in south
vietnam i want to start a complete and
very profound review of how we got into
this country and what we thought we were
doing and what we now think we can do i
even want to think about whether or not
we should be there
i want to consider how some kind of a
gradual shift in our presence in south
vietnam can occur
just as a withdrawal plan moved to
implementation president kennedy was
assassinated on november 22 bringing the
process to a close his successor lyndon
johnson promised to continue his
predecessor's domestic and foreign
policies but in an abrupt change of
direction the new president bowed to the
joint chiefs wishes and revised nsam 273
by raising the level of covert
operations against hanoi the proposal
codenamed oplan 34a
led to the gulf of tonkin crisis of
august 64 followed by an americanized
war
had kennedy lived would he have pursued
the withdrawal plan
nothing suggests that he would have
given up his attempt to return the
military commitment to its early 61
level
never in his thousand days in office did
he stray from the principle that the war
was south vietnam's to win or lose nor
in light of the bay of pigs fiasco is
there reason to believe that he would
have turned over the war to the joint
chiefs to tone down the cold war thrust
of the nation's foreign policy the
president intended to replace the
hard-line rusk with mcnamara as
secretary of state
the critical point is that kennedy was
willing to pull out all special military
forces short of victory the president
sought to reduce the u.s involvement not
end it
president kennedy's central tragedy lies
in his promoting a coup aimed at
facilitating a military withdrawal from
vietnam
for his actions tied the u.s more
closely to vietnam and thereby
stonewalled his plan to bring the troops
home
so carefully had he analyzed the risks
of sending combat troops
not so carefully had he analyzed the
risks of promoting a coup
his legacy was a highly volatile
situation in vietnam that in the hands
of a leader seeking a quick solution
lay open to full-scale military
escalation the new president soon
americanized the war
resulting in the death of a generation
i thank you very much for your time
we do have some time for questions from
the audience uh we will conclude a
little bit with our book signing but
let's go to some questions i do know
that we have some very talented students
from washington lee high school from
arlington virginia how about we start
with y'all any questions from your group
[Music]
sir uh professor jones
i'm wondering about the participants in
the two
of the generals
are any of them still around were you
able to talk to any of them and were
people like like two or key involved
two was yes two was one of the generals
involved in it and he was the one in
fact who led the the siege on the palace
as the one later the president on in
1971. uh the others i was not able to
talk with i believe most of them have
passed on their number though who have
left their memoirs and i was able to
piece some things together from that but
of course that's not always he was not
involved no
okay we'll go to the arlington school
yes
sir thank you um
you start off along the same lines
talking about the the generals
who are promoting the coup you started
off by saying that they
they initially wanted merely to keep the
gm in office as figurehead but then
changed their mind and wanted to have
them exiled i was wondering what was it
that made them change their mind
i think they were they were very much
concerned about ziem coming back i mean
this had happened so many times
one time a man had run up to shoot him
and the gun didn't go off and a couple
of other times they came so close to
getting him and it just didn't work out
and he just seemed to always come back
and i think as a couple people said
after the deaths of them that big men
had ordered them because they were
scared to death of these two that they
indeed might come back now i think what
they decided at this point was that they
would keep the whole affair legitimate
in the sense that it would be a
bloodless coup they would not kill them
they would go into exile and according
to conan the whole thing was staged with
the press involved everyone was there
ready to witness all of this and then
they disappeared in the tunnel
let's go on the very back dr rogers
speaking of lyndon johnson where was
lyndon johnson when all this was going
on what was he doing did he express any
opinions lyndon johnson very much
opposed the involvement in the coup very
strongly opposed that but he didn't
really have a voice in it he had gone to
vietnam in may of 61 on a on a friendly
mission goodwill mission as you probably
know about that but in terms of sitting
in on these big meetings he sat in on
some of them but you don't hear any
voices from him but when he did become
president he made the statement that he
strongly opposed the coup
yes sir
mr um
i think there's a
paradox in your talk and let me suggest
two reasons why i think that one is
you said and i think this is a quote
that uh john f kennedy
that the president sought to reduce the
u.s commitment not end it
now
the united states is not going to make a
commitment to the ho chi minh government
that's just not going to happen so when
you say that president sought to reduce
the u.s commitment you mean while the
south vietnam regime stays in power and
so the question comes up and this is
something lbj could never figure it out
neither could richard nixon how do we
keep on supporting this regime while it
keeps on losing the war i mean it isn't
ultimately then the president likely had
he lived to reverse himself because his
policy is a paradox well
john kenneth galbraith i was fortunate
enough to talk with him he's in his 90s
and sharp as can be and he indicated
that and i know that he talked with
kennedy many times on a personal level
he had been his campaign manager back in
60 and very close to him all these years
and he indicated that the whole
atmosphere of the white house when he
saw it during this time was that of just
imminent defeat and that the president
if he had not become convinced that
defeat was coming there certainly wasn't
going to be the victory that everyone
had talked about before and so victory
became defined by president kennedy as
under vietnamization that you reduce the
insurgency to the level that the
government there would have a chance to
control it now would that government
ever be able to control that that's uh
that's the big question and
i think what galbraith would have said
and i know he said this and some others
as well is that they had written it off
that they were going to maintain mag
there the military assistance advisory
group but mcv was just not going to have
the
high profile role it had before we were
going to reduce it back to the way it
was back in 1961 and just
get out
yeah i know exactly what and i've
wrestled with that sure
you mentioned also that the uh one of
the criticisms of diem in his regime was
that he was maybe soft on negotiating he
was maybe willing to negotiate with the
north
that sounds like that undercuts some of
it i mean that's a way to end it yeah
well you mean in terms of talking with
hanoi yes and if that wouldn't work then
that's a way for us to get out of
vietnam and that's one of the reasons we
overthrew him
well frederick nolting said and you have
to keep in mind that he was very pro-gen
in fact that's why he was relieved from
his command a large part of it although
there was a calendar of events that
would take him out around that time
anyway but then lodge took over knolting
said several times that vietcong agents
were showing up in the palace and
talking with zim and talking with new
and he strongly suggested that new was
trying to negotiate something trying to
buy some time
that
he was in a desperate situation at this
point that the generals were all up in
arms around him and he just decided he
was going to try to buy some time by
negotiating with them and i think what
happened was that the word got out to
the generals that he was negotiating
with him it was pretty obvious what was
going to happen to them if he did buy
some time
before we go on to our next question
what's interesting that dr jones knows
saying the viewing audience may not
realize is in the audience tonight we
have people who served in the vietnam
war those who served on the president's
staff during the war as well as people
who weren't even born when the war took
place so it's great how we get this
variety of questions
mr foley yes sir yes sir
lansdale went back into vietnam i
believe
later later he did yeah
what was the occasion that he went into
back into vietnam this was under lyndon
johnson sometime afterward but
president kennedy had called him in and
surprised him in 1962 and asked him if
he would head this task force on cuba
and he was quite shocked by this but
then of course took it along with robert
kennedy and that was of course the whole
operation mongoose affair
back to arlington yes sir uh yeah um
from your presentation i definitely got
the impression that
the uh kennedy administration believed
that new was the major problem with gm's
government
uh was there ever any indication that zm
would remove new from power without
being forced to or was it clearly a
matter of dm goes with new
what
really was interesting was that even
more than new
who infuriated the kennedy
administration was madame knew
she got under the skin of these people
so many times there was one meeting and
i never found out who said this but it
was quote in the back
to zim can't you shut up that woman
she would criticize and she she was
known as a dragon lady lady she was the
woman who wore the tight skirt that was
slid up the side and the reporter said
it was like a dagger and a sheath and
that she was just pure she was
the lucretia borja of the times and all
of this i mean she said things that just
cut them to the quick and so not only
was she there pushing new then of course
new had his vbi his vietnamese bureau of
investigation his hound dogs his secret
police and all of this kind of thing and
they were operating the special forces
who had been cia trained and they were
the ones working with him as well
and then you've got ziem who is not
married
and madame new is in effect the first
lady for him during this time
and he he can't he can't control her one
time she told him to just simply shut up
about your remarks about my clothing she
just simply would not listen to him as
well and so what the administration
thought was the way to change things and
it made sense get rid of the news
but
zm had gotten himself into the position
where he trusted no one but family and
within his family his closest confidants
were his brother and his wife
and so there was no way he was going to
remove them he was his chief advisor on
an unofficial level but clearly his
chief and closest confidant
so there was no way that was going to
work out
for two questions carl
i'd like to share this gentleman's
skepticism and
raise a counter argument and see what
your response would be
i have to paraphrase it but i i think
people remember the remark i believe it
was in kennedy's inaugural address
where he said something about uh
in the preservation of freedom we would
you know fight every battle i think you
know the quote
um if he says something like that
he then participates in this coup which
maybe it didn't produce the result they
thought but nonetheless it was very
clear what our involvement was in this
thing
and then things begin to disintegrate in
vietnam as they did after this thing
occurred
how could we then walk away from this i
mean it would seem to me that the
entire credibility of the u.s government
not just in vietnam but credibility in
general
would be demolished if something like
this would have we just kind of
did this how could they kind of how
could we contemplate that if that's what
happened and we know that is what
happened after this coup i know that the
the vital interest of the us throughout
this is what dean rush talked about the
credibility the credibility gap that
developed later and so forth but this is
again before the gulf of tonkin this is
before all those events later on and
president kennedy i'm convinced thought
that we will cut it back to an advisory
level we'll try to hang on as long as we
can there and maybe that will work and
if it doesn't work then we're going to
have to just call it a wash i know i
know that doesn't fit i know i've
wrestled with that over and over and i
can't i can't make it all come together
yet in my mind i know
would you comment on maxwell taylor's
relationship with president kennedy and
his relationship with the other joint
chiefs and how they affected each effect
in his policy recommendations
well maxwell taylor was
as far as i could tell about the only
general that president kennedy liked
he curtis lemay
he could not he just simply couldn't be
in the same room with him in fact
roswell kilpatrick said about him that
every time president kennedy met with
curtis lemay he would come out and
kennedy would be in a fit he couldn't
speak it was gibberish he says no
civilized country can have a curtis
lemay he made that comment
now maxwell taylor though was different
maxwell taylor had written books maxwell
taylor had exalted the principle of
flexible response in the dullest times
which of course made him very unpopular
at that time and after the bay of pigs
fiasco in which president kennedy just
not really rode off the joint chiefs not
really rode off the ca but certainly
determined that he was not going to
listen to them first they just because
they were experts he was going to listen
to others before but in the after in the
aftermath of the bay of pigs he invited
maxwell taylor to come in and try to
pick up the pieces and try to give us
some direction on where to go in our
foreign policy and taylor came in and
according to kennedy's
talks about him he was handsome he was
intelligent and he was not the typical
martial kind of person and he said that
it was just like the aftermath of verdun
when he walked into the cabinet meeting
the the morale was just rock bottom and
so he had to try to get them up and
kennedy had him as his special advisor
and later on of course became the chair
of the joint chiefs but what is also
interesting was that he became as the
days and weeks and months passed an
advocate of sending american combat
troops
he was the one that was involved with
rostow in drawing up this plan of
sending a logistical task force in to
resolve the flood control flood problems
in the mekong delta and this was a cover
there was no question for bringing in
around eight to ten thousand american
troops and president kennedy saw through
that and he said i am not going to send
combat troops into that country that is
like taking a drink you take one the
effect wears off and then you've got to
have another and it'll never end so i'm
not going to send the first combat
troops in granted he sent a lot of
advisers
and yes they fought a secret war there's
no question about that
but he also
would not allow them to take the
offensive and as it turned out he tried
to turn the corner back
dr joe's final question uh what's coming
up next what's your next book
i'm working on a book on the diplomacy
of the civil war for north carolina
well it's something to look forward to
ladies and gentlemen i want to thank
book team me i want to thank you all for
coming and especially
[Applause]
howard jones is a history professor at
the university of alabama
death of a generation is published by
oxford university press
visit
oupdashusa.org for more information
next week on history on book tv jack